K if someone has been on one career path
or has had one life calling let's say
and they decide they want to change
course what's your advice to
them we saw so many people in the
pandemic realize life is short and
you've got to follow your passion you've
got to do what you love you've got to do
what lights you up and so a lot of folks
have circled back to what is my calling
what was in my heart when I was a
teenager and my 20s maybe I gave up that
path um and then certainly the young
people who maybe feel even more
ambitious than ever about I don't want
to compromise I want to go after what
really is important to me so my best
advice is to take every advantage that
you can give yourself going into the
entertainment business going into
Hollywood um my own personal regret
bring oh I wish I went to law school I
was a development exact but oh my gosh
had I I gone to law school and had some
comprehension of contracts going in I
would have been so much better
positioned and so those types of
decisions okay this is my calling I
really want to work above the line
writer director showrunner producer how
could you arm yourself what advantages
could you give yourself living in Los
Angeles is an advantage living in New
York is an advantage making sure you
have a great Wi-Fi connection in your
house so that your Zoom calls don't drop
off if you're taking meetings outside
the business cuz we have opened up
virtually now to folks who are not
living in the major epicenters of the
industry so looking at your life that
way how could I give myself more
advantages one of the biggest advantages
you can think about giving yourself is
what I call finding your wolf pack who
are the others who could partner with
you who you just you love to breathe
their air they excite you creatively
maybe you admire their writing or you
admire they're film making or just
somebody that makes you laugh and you
get along with them and like oh my gosh
they just always crack me up great
partner with them what could you work on
together maybe you could even do a short
film together work on getting a feature
together that is something that the
industry always relates to and responds
to oh partnership this team of people
are doing this and when there's an
energy around it that can be a big draw
especially for buyers who go oh that's
interesting producer goes this has some
momentum uh and that can really help you
those types of
advantages what is reframing failure and
how have you implemented this in your
life failure is a topic that up until
recent times has just really been taboo
you might feel ashamed you've had some
failures and you don't want to admit
that to anyone or maybe your family has
even come down on you like oh we
expected better from you so then we
internalize those voices and then we can
even turn against ourselves so how do
you reframe failure well it's important
to realize that all the most successful
people whether you're talking about Elon
Musk or Michael Jordan or Margaret
Atwood they have had significant
failures in their lives and in their
past that has built their character
built their Drive taught them oh I
shouldn't go that way I should go this
way I get better results if I do that
and then so normalizing failure for us
oh it's an experiment for myself even in
my business or in my own writing I
always say this is an
experiment then it's like oh if it
completely Burns To The Ground okay well
that experiment didn't work out let's
try a new experiment so it lowers the
pressure doesn't have to just be a
success and knock it out of the park all
the time because then that ends up
becoming a burden of pressure that you
put on yourself so that's one way that I
recommend navigating failures through
your own selft talk this is an
experiment I'm going to try this I'm
going to try that and then it can be
playful and fun the entertainment
industry really loves people who are
bringing in joy and fun and a sense of
what I call in the entertainment
business school awesomeness just be
awesome bring awesomeness and then
people go what's happening over there
with you you know and they want to get
to know you because you bring in your
best self your best Spirit but failure
is part of the business across the board
there are failures I mean when I was a
development exec we had movies that
didn't do well at the box office and we
had to process that and go okay well if
we if we invested in that we all
believed in that and it didn't work out
what can we learn from that so we can
make a better decision next time and we
would have those debrief meetings so if
there's anyone in your life that you can
debrief with who you trust who is part
of your wolf pack who could say let's
let's reframe the failure for yourself
as something that you learned that is a
mistake you won't make again so that you
can get the lesson and then make a
different mistake next time cuz I think
the biggest failure that any of us could
have is making the same mistake over and
over that's the kind of truest failure
but if you actually make a mistake
things go sideways you learn from it
then you get to make a new mistake next
time and then you can start to feel like
your own growth as a human being is tied
to your creative path and I think that
that's the best any of us can hope for
it's important to remember Leonardo da
Vinci was not famous in his lifetime he
was passed over for the cinee chapel he
was a gay man who was imprisoned for
sodomy who couldn't even live his best
life out in public and he was discovered
hundred years after he died so I'm a
historian and if you look back through
history you go oh my gosh there are so
many incredible examples of artists who
were recognized long after they passed
because they left Legacy they left
something of value so if you have
decided this is my call in this is my
path stay really close to your Muse to
your inner voice that says how can I be
give something back how can I give
something back to others to the world
through my art and you kind of have to
let it go knowing um one of my producing
partner says it's better to have too
many babies than a spoiled baby so you
don't necessarily get to know oh I hope
this project goes but you don't really
know if it will go you can hope and hope
and pray but if you a few projects then
you have more of a chance of knowing
okay that one failed that one failed oh
but this one did really well well you
had said too that someone gave you the
advice that the entertainment industry
loves people who are busy pretty and
forgive me I forgot the other one happy
busy pretty okay happy busy pretty what
if someone says well that's not in my
nature how can we sort of present that
even though once they get to know us
they find out we actually do great work
so that's a quote that's a little out of
context let me give you the context my
friend Juliet Lando and I are always
joking about and laughing that this
industry only wants you to look happy
busy and pretty all day every day you
can't let any of the warts show and
that's not human but yet if you go back
through film history it's Glamour and
it's Optics and it's image and all these
things so there's a lot of challenges to
living in our modern times today but one
of the beautiful maybe Silver Linings to
all the challenges that we face is that
we do get to be a bit more real and I
think we're all craving feeling like
someone is real think about the show
that you watched most recently that you
really really loved there's probably a
character from that show that was real
that somehow whether they were funny or
more dramatic they felt so real to you
and alive and like someone you might
even want to be friends with and I think
at the end of the to day that's what
we're all craving that's what execs are
craving that's what showrunners want to
staff in their rooms you might be
watching Star Trek and it's completely
you know it's genre and it's sci-fi and
it's other worlds but then you realize
oh but I love do Crusher I love peard
these are people who I wish I could know
in real life and because there's
resonance because it feels real
audiences tune in that's what we want we
want to feel something we want to laugh
we want to cry we want to connect so
being happy busy pretty even though this
industry is like we just want you to do
that it actually is full of real people
execs are real people they're like tell
me your story what do you want me to
know about you and this is what really
will help you in your career is getting
in touch with your realness who are you
that you can really bring forward go to
the depths we say like right from your
marrow you know if if an actor is really
embodied they're bringing something real
it's not just gloss and I think that's
what audiences crave long for want to
connect with we're wanting to get past
the the foe image and get to something
deeper and real think about a hit like
the the bear which was almost a little
bit of a sleeper hit like they didn't
have a huge budget at the beginning in
their first season but by season two so
much realness the audiences are going oh
my God this is writing is incredible and
I feel like I know these people and I
want to know these people and they
really penetrated a much bigger audience
I think for that quality that they were
bringing through the screen and if using
that example again this is not a show
about happy busy and pretty this is a
show about real about here's the scars
here's the wounds here's the crazy
relationships and we're all I think
longing for that coming out of a
horrific pandemic and then in the
entertainment business the strikes and
the work stoppages which were also
painful for so many of us and for my
students as well that we're all going
how can we build something better um how
can we build something that feels more
real to all of us that's more fun
hopefully CU if you're being fake you're
not having fun that's just the truth of
it but if you're being real you're going
to make real connections real
connections with your own Wolfpack and
also with your audience
and as you grow your career that's who
you want to have you know in the ripple
effect of your creative works is like oh
the audience who I have fans and they
love what I did an example I use and
teach from in the entertainment business
school is Mystery Science Theater 3000
and Joel Hodson and you know I grew up
in my teen years watching these silly
robots and this ventriloquist make jokes
about these be movies and we would just
laugh and laugh and he de developed such
a huge fan base that people who are like
oh we love him it's so creative it's so
real it's so funny and you would never
expect like an exec if you were pitching
I'm going to pitch you a show with a
ventriloquist and a couple of robots and
we're going to make jokes about be
movies I don't know many exacts who
would be like oh yeah let's greenl that
you know but that when he's coming from
that real place that Joel Hudson was as
a Creator huge fan base real
connection